people of the internet retro recontour
here and in today's video we're going to
be talking about the new hit ps5 title
returnal and five ways it's similar to
one of my favorite series of all time
metroid oh dude this actually reminds me
the opening of metroid prime right there
remember metroid prime when it's like
looking up and then it like
it pans down
and then you get the ba
[Music]
now a lot of these comparisons will be
to metroid prime however there are some
to the older 2d metroid games as well
prime may be a first-person shooter or
first-person adventure as nintendo
preferred to call it
while returnal is a third-person
roguelike but there are still numerous
elements along the way that make it
pretty clear to me how smart took at
least some
inspiration from the metroid series
number one
the atmosphere for both games it really
starts with the atmosphere
this struck me almost immediately when i
booted up paterno for the first
time sure there are plenty of games that
take place in space but not all of them
focus on the quiet mystery of space
begging to be explored from the moment
celine's ship crashes onto an unfamiliar
planet you're met by a dark yet lush
environment with rain falling
overhead mysterious vegetation and
ancient runes waiting to be deciphered
it really reminded me of the early
scenes in metroid prime when samus lands
on talon 4 for the first time
also in the rain met with plants and
vegetation
as well as various artifacts to be
analyzed both games nail that strange
sense of being
isolated out in space yet surrounded by
the unfamiliar at the same time
the environments are packed with detail
encouraging you to uncover all their
secrets
i also can't say enough about the slick
menu system and hud in each game
prime may have felt a little more
immersive because of its first person
perspective which gave retro studios the
chance to have the game's menu appear as
part of samus's visor which worked
incredibly well even though celine's
adventure is third person the menu is
also incredibly slick
futuristic and perhaps most important of
all informative
number two scanning and item discovery
to learn more about the planets in each
game you'll have the ability to scan
objects and artifacts along the way
in prime you have the ability to switch
to your scan visor at any time and look
over the world for scannable objects
returnal has opted instead for a
contextual approach where prompts will
appear on screen when you're near an
item that can be scanned
to this day prime is a game that
receives near unanimous praise yet one
of the few qualms some like to nitpick
is the scanning and maybe the
overuse of said scanning with returnal
keeping the scanning only as needed it's
possible it will avoid this criticism
i for one enjoy it in both games it
feels like a very natural way for
someone exploring an unfamiliar planet
to learn more about the world
the in-game menus in both games also do
an excellent job of displaying and
categorizing this information in case
you need to reference it again
later on number three weapon and suit
upgrades
this right here has been a staple of
metroid games
since the original you lose all your
abilities and then you slowly
gather them back including new abilities
throughout the game
from missiles to a dash ability to the
morph ball to morph ball bombs
samus has quite the arsenal to take on
space pirates
with house mark's pedigree it should
come as no surprise that the weapons in
returnal are
incredible like metroid you'll gather
upgrades along the way that enhance your
abilities
including allowing you to reach areas
that you couldn't before
to explore the world you'll need both
weapon and suit upgrades
and whereas metroid's power-ups are
pretty clear-cut
returnal instead has power-ups that can
actually hinder you
while they help you it's a careful
trade-off and one that i'm really
enjoying so
far in return number four female
heroines
that feel similar back in 1986 with the
original metroid nintendo surprised the
gaming world with a series of secret
endings that revealed the game's
protagonist
was actually female now here in 2021
this may not seem like a big deal as
more and more games feature female leads
these days but back then this was quite
a surprise to many
samus remains a gaming icon even today
no thanks to nintendo might i add
seriously
just give us the prime collection
already so here we are in 2021 and it's
not a huge surprise to have celine as
the main protagonist for eternal but
credit to games like metroid tomb raider
perfect dark and plenty of others that
have helped pave the way but it's not
just the fact that they're women with
blonde hair in a spacesuit
celine also controls similar to how
samus moves in the 2d titles like super
metroid and metroid fusion you'll notice
right away that she's fast and has a
dash ability to help her cross long gaps
it certainly tends to lean more to the
arcadey side of things than the
realistic side of things
and as far as this specific aspect goes
this is actually different from the
prime games which moved more like a
traditional fps
except for maybe when samus was in the
morph ball mode at number five we have
world navigation both the map and vault
doors in return
look as if they were ripped straight out
of metroid prime and i totally say that
as a compliment now seriously just check
out the map right here this one's from
metroid prime and then compare it to
what we have here
with return all these look so similar
guys and you know nothing wrong with us
i think this is great inspiration from
house mark looking back at what retro
studios did and it actually works really
really well
in both games now any metroid fan is
gonna know a series staple is
backtracking going through areas that
you've already seen once
but now you have a special ability or a
special item that you didn't have before
that's going to allow you into an area
you couldn't reach
now i'm still early in return but i've
already noticed some things like this
now of course the format for eternal is
very different it is a roguelike
with a procedural nature so it's
certainly not that same
exact open world in the sense that you
see in something like metroid prime or
even super metroid
what prime does so well and what eternal
is doing well so far
is the sense of progression what's
interesting about those doors in metroid
prime is retro
actually used it as a clever way to hide
some of the loading screens
in fact there really were no loading
screens whatsoever in metroid prime
unless you count the little elevator
sequence which
again was kind of a clever way for retro
to hide loading to a new area
with playstation 5 super fast ssd it
doesn't seem like housemark is using it
as a way to hide loading but in terms of
the design perspective to me it is
clearly inspired by the doors of metroid
prime you'll even come across
red doors but you need a special key to
access metroid had various types of
doors as well which required you to
switch to a different beam or even
require the missile
now guys i am still in the early hours
of return
so i can't wait to see what else i find
as i play along this is actually my
first return
video so if you guys are enjoying this
and you're also a metroid fan let me
know what similarities you have found
which ones did i miss
which ones did you notice as well and if
you want to see more videos like this
hit that thumbs up before you go
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon